nouveau rebondissement dans l'affairé
grégory médiatique est surprenant le
très discret juge simon se met à parler
au point que il l'a confirmé lui-même
tout à leur plainte a été déposée contre
lui les détails véronique gaurel pour la
deuxième fois en deux mois le juge simon
rompt le silence je sais avait il
déclaré à une chaîne de télévision
aujourd'hui il va beaucoup plus loin
trois révélations pour un entretien au
nouveau détective 1
le juge simon semble convaincu de
l'heure du crime le petit grégory
auraient été noyés après 17h30 à cette
heure-là christine villemin participent
déjà aux recherches une heure qui
innocenteraient la mère de grégory
deuxième révélation le petit grégory
aurait été assassiné par plusieurs
personnes trois hypothèses sont retenues
les 3 évoqués bernard laroche peut être
at il relevé gregori de là à être son
assassinat il y à un pack pour le moment
je ne peux pas franchir ajoute le juge
réaction vive et immédiate de l'avocat
de marie-ange laroche
ils demandent que le juge simon soit
dessaisi pour violation du secret de
l'instruction
un juge qui ne respectent pas les règles
de l'instruction reste il un magistrat
instructeur crédible je vous pose la
question la réponse est évidemment d'eau
alors comment cela va se passer c'est ce
que nous voulons dire avec voir avec le
garde des sceaux et à lui d'agir pour
que la justice à dijon fonctionne comme
doit fonctionner la justice française
troisième révélation le juge estimant
affirme avoir reçu des menaces de mort
contre lui et ses petits enfants
ce qui me trouble dit il c'est que seuls
les grands parents de grégory
connaissent l'existence de ma famille
l'avocat de monique albert villemin
attend un démenti écoutez ça serait
extrêmement grave imaginer qu'un
magistrat instructeur pense que les
parties civiles demain
par lettre anonyme il serait à ce moment
là impossible de travailler ensemble
ce soir le juge simon s'était interrogé
à sa sortie du palais de justice de
dijon il a simplement répondu il y à une
plainte contre moi je répondrai devant
le juge kim interrogera autre silence
compréhensible celui de jean marie et
christine villemin
il se refuse ce soir à tout commentaire